foreign
section that I was just reading from in
the Brookings Institute thing you don't
need to show my screen here Zach
some podcasters also cited
non-peer-reviewed preprints and data
which often contained faulty statistical
analysis or poor research designs to
bolster their prior beliefs on the
efficacy of ivermectin for instance
while summarily dismissing similar
non-peer-reviewed studies whose
conclusions ran contrary to their
preferences
I read that and then by chance because I
get
Nature and Science into my inbox
whenever they put out a new issue I I
saw this which you can show
my screen now this from nature this week
this is nature news so your nature is
one of the two most prominent science
journals in the world and they also have
a basically a new section so it's a
great source for uh Science News Cova
drug drives viral mutations and now some
won't want to Halt its use analysis
reveals the signature of the antiviral
drug monopurovir and starts cov2
sequences riddled with mutations
so there's a lot to talk about there and
I don't know that we're going to talk
about most of it right now but I just
want to point out that nature
um which is not a right wing political
podcast riddle with misinformation is
that what we are nature's not I think we
can all agree
um this is
um this study was post what this study
was posted on the med rxiv preprint
server in January it is not up in
peer-reviewed but why is nature talking
about it then goodness there's probably
statistical errors in there that the
peers would certainly have discovered
because the peers definitely know the
difference between uh
right causation and correlation which of
course
um
pretends that the effect of peer review
is to vastly increase the quality of
what is published and that is actually a
testable hypothesis I'm trying to
remember somebody wrote a very good I
believe it was a sub stack evaluating
peer reviews effectiveness at this very
thing I read it a couple weeks ago I
will attempt to dig it up assuming I can
find it we will put it in the in the
notes of this podcast but the point is
peer review is actually a failure in
this regard and we acknowledge that the
point that we talked about many things
on the preprint servers that that does
increase the amount of noise however
what it means is that you don't have all
of the skill buggery that takes place in
the so-called peer review process
interfering with your ability to know
what's going on you basically have a raw
scientific discussion and you have to
sort wheat from chaff which is what we
do and that's yeah part of what we did
from the beginning now and we've talked
about peer review many many times on
this podcast including very early on in
our discussion back in like March or
April 2020
uh you know it the idea sounds brilliant
it's not inherent to the scientific
process at all
um what is is uh opening up your ideas
to be challenged by friend info like
that that is an important part of the
scientific process but peer review is
not peer review is basically a modern
invention to deal with the fact that we
you know there's a lot of people trying
to do science now and trying to get the
attention of you know even our larger
number of people
um
but uh peer review itself it actually
acts more like a gated community now
than like an actual ability to to sort
wheat from chat you know I mentioned
earlier that I used to do peer review uh
and uh very often when I would say you
know right sort of the things that you
can recommend are like this is awesome
no change is necessary uh this is really
good but there's a couple things you
know I'd like to know more about what
this analysis was you know they need to
look at the literature over here this
that and the other
um you know or recommend to uh to
project those are you know usually more
categories than that but this is sort of
the three categories that is a peer
reviewer you're you're offered uh to
recommend for a paper and uh very rarely
when I said recommend to reject on
account of there's no hypothesis but
they're pretending there was uh was the
paper actually rejected because you know
peer review is often done as sort of
like a majority vote it's like okay with
the editor is going to send this out to
three possible peer reviewers and
they're going to come back and if I'm
the only one who gives a damn about
there not being a hypothesis then the
paper is not going to be rejected and
it's going to you know go into
literature yeah it's a very it's a very
arbitrary filter yeah uh that often
introduces errors it sends authors back
to do things that are unnecessary it and
you know and the the differences between
the pure the peer reviewers is it's it's
funny like this it's its own it's its
own literature it's a completely broken
process that has really no purpose right
it's really a holdover from a time in
which there was a limit to the amount of
stuff that you could publish because ink
and paper were expensive and so that
space had a value yeah
um and the fact is this stuff is now
electronically published why should
anyone be in a position to stop you from
publishing a piece of work because it's
bad if it's bad it doesn't stand up but
if it's great and somebody said it was
bad because they were your competitor
and they didn't want to see the light of
day why should that have any weight at
all well so you know if I'm if I'm in a
steel man on you know why journals why
editors right there's too much
information uh and we all have to
we all have to figure out some ways to
funnel our attention to ex you know to
exclude some of the things that want our
attention so that we can focus on this
and I've told this story before too but
you know we we are generalists we have
done very you know very focused highly
specialized work in a number of Demands
but we are more or less generalists as
in general is uh the approach to
understanding life that is evolutionary
biology
but I remember the you know two-day
interview that I had when I was applying
for the job at Evergreen
I had an hour free between all the
different interviews and such and I went
to the library and the library was
pretty bad it was very bad I was a
little you know a Podunk Library without
very many journals at all and this would
have been in two thousand two I guess
and so there wasn't as much available
online and I went to one of the faculty
on the committee that was deciding
whether or not to hire me and said how
do you how do you do your work here I
don't like I don't I don't see how you
can do your work when this is the
library you have access to and this
person who I respect greatly said oh I
subscribed to the three journals I need
and that's it that's all I need
I thought well but I don't just I don't
even know which three journals I would
choose I mean I
probably named three to really tell me
you can only look at three scientific
journals ever for the rest of your life
I'd pick three but they certainly
wouldn't be like you know in this
particular little field it doesn't let
you do generalist work it doesn't let
you do your generalist work and you know
especially given that nature and science
like all the journals are now so much
crappier than they used to be and not
honoring you know good science at all uh
you know the idea that oh I just I look
at the thing that I need to look at that
I'm interested in now like even if that
is good for you now because the
particular research program you're doing
now for the next six months or a year
really does take you into that space
how about letting your mind expand and
go into an adjacent space an adjacent
space and over here and over here and
over here and you know that is one of
the things that the internet has allowed
that you don't need access to the
Library of Alexandria or whatever it's
modern uh Counterpoint is you can say oh
oh okay and this you know this is
actually some of the work that I did for
Bob trivers back when I was his research
assistant as an undergrad before you
know
the early 90s you know he'd be he'd read
a paper and be like oh wow what oh I
want to see these references go get them
but you know it was a generalist well
who's a generalist still is right
um and he'd say you know this is this is
my job for him like I would run back and
forth between his office and the library
and get the references and photocopy
them and bring them back and he quickly
say I'm like oh this reference and go
back and now you can do that without
having to hire a research assistant
right so and it was amazing and
if you really are only saying oh I'm
only interested in these little things
here
well you're not going to be able to see
the bigger picture and therefore you are
inherently going to be missing at least
some of what is true and maybe all of it
a couple points one
the reason though there has been a
dramatic narrowing of focus graduate
school Narrows you to focus on a
question so small that you can't get
scooped because you're the only expert
or there's one or two others and you
know what they're working on right yeah
and it's a terrible process from the
point of view of getting the most bang
for the buck out of science you want
people as generalists a they make much
better teachers right if you want to
teach the Next Generation how to think
and what's true you don't want somebody
who trained very narrowly you want
somebody who trained broadly but B the
Innovations of a generalist are likely
to be much more consequential right the
point is they're not some narrowly
focused thing which yes maybe you know
there's some cure for cancer lurking in
your narrow little realm but probably
not right if you're going to find some
general principle that is actually going
to level up a bunch of different
disciplines it's going to be a
generalist who finds it the second thing
is
um you you bristled a little bit at my
claim that who's why should peers be
able to stop you from publishing your
thing just because they say it's bad the
fact is maybe I just said I can defend
why editors and journals exist well I'm
not arguing that editors in journal
shouldn't exist maybe they should I
think by and large they're terrible not
the only thing that should accept but
the point is that should be no bar to
your putting your work somewhere where
it can be of value if it takes 500 years
for your work to turn out to have been
prescient right the fact that people
were wrong for 499 years after you did
it is not an argument against people
reading it that's in fact they should be
able to go back and find out you know
this person was dismissed at the time
turns out they were right and so the the
whole idea that we are being taken to
task
or reading the unpeer-reviewed
literature as if peer review was any
good at all which it isn't right it's a
it's a it's a
um it's a negative influence for many
many reasons but the idea that we are
being taken to task nature is not being
taken to task because it obviously uses
the uh unpeer-reviewed literature and
the whole point here is to put a shackle
on our ankles not to actually apply some
standard generally but
um but the fact is look that literature
is what it is and yes you need to
realize that nobody has vetted it for
you but the vetting doesn't work so okay
there's a lot of there's a lot of chaff
in order to get to the wheat you got to
be better at it but that is the point
and who's going to be good at it
generalists
[Music]
thank you